[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about
compressed sensing and how we are able
to reconstruct a full high-resolution
image or whatever signal we're working
with audio signal image from a dramatic
sub sampling of the information so even
if I only had a small number of random
pixels from that image can we infer what
the Fourier coefficients the active
Fourier coefficients in that image are
in this vector s the sparse vector s and
then can we use those to reconstruct the
full image in X okay so we're gonna walk
through now the math of how to do this
okay good so this is kind of the matrix
form a pictorial form of this system of
equations that I've written down here
okay so sy is our universal transform
basis in this case I think this is a
discrete cosine basis but you can think
of it as some Fourier basis or some
wavelet basis s is my sparse vector of
coefficients here this is kind of a
cartoon where there's only three nonzero
coefficients everything else is zero so
here white is zero okay
and why is my measurement so this C
matrix here what C is doing this is my
measurement matrix it is basically
pulling rows of side x s side times s is
X my original image so C pulling rows of
this basically means it's sampling
pixels from X so Y is just a subsample
of random pixels from X okay that's what
Y is now this system of equations is
what's called underdetermined this is
really important this is an under
determined system of equations and we've
seen this before in the SVD chapter
we've seen systems that are under
determined before we have measurements
of Y we know what C and P I R we know
which pixels we measured and we know
what our Fourier transform basis is and
we're trying to solve for s the sparse
vector of coefficients that is
consistent with those measurements okay
now there are
this Y vector has only a few entries in
it and s might have a million entries
and so there are infinitely many
solutions of this system of equations
there's infinitely many S's that when I
multiply by C times I I will get back at
this measurement Y and that's what I
mean by underdetermined is that out of
all of those infinitely many S's how do
I find the right one that is actually
the Fourier coefficients of my my image
okay
and so this is where it gets really
interesting in this this is again this
is an underdetermined inverse problem
okay so because we're basically trying
to invert Y to solve for s that's called
an inverse problem so this is an
underdetermined inverse problem and so
we're gonna have to use additional
information out of all of these
infinitely many S's we're gonna have to
use additional information to find this
very special particular s for you know
in our Fourier transform basis okay now
if you had written down this math
problem you could have written this down
a hundred years ago and people would
understand basically what you're trying
to do but you wouldn't have been able to
solve for this s finding the very
particular s that satisfies this
equations that happens to be thus Parsis
s in your Fourier basis people wouldn't
have been able to solve that problem
it's called a combinatorial e hard
problem you literally have to try all
combinations of entries to try to find
the Sparsit
s that satisfies the system of equations
okay and it's only in the last 15 years
that huge advances in applied math and
statistics have given us algorithms to
solve for the sparsit's
s the s with the most zeros that
satisfies this equation in a scalable
robust fashion so there is great work by
Donahoe and can des and Romberg and tau
biruni a crop many others there is a
huge literature on this starting in the
kind of
early two-thousands like 2004 to 2006
that developed a mathematical framework
to solve for the very particular s that
we're looking for out of this infinitely
many solutions and the s that we're
looking for
we want the sparsit's s so solve for the
sparse cysts s out of all possible s's
that you could solve for and remember
that's based on this fundamental
observation that all signals are
compressible in these Universal
transform bases so X when I afford when
I Fourier transform it is going to be
ultra ultra sparse so what I'm looking
for is a vector S that satisfies this
system of equations and is as sparse as
possible good ok so there are many many
ways to to solve for s here and I'm just
going to write down a few different ways
of writing this optimization problem and
then show you what this looks like
ok so what I could write down is I could
write down then we're trying to minimize
we're trying to find s that minimizes C
times sy times s minus y and we're going
to try to minimize this in the two norm
because I just want I want Y and C times
side times s to be as close as possible
and effectively I want this to be 0 I
want to find s that exactly satisfies
this but remember there are infinitely
many S's that satisfy that and so what i
can do is i can add on this penalty term
so there's some constant lambda just a
number that tells me how important this
next term is times the norm of s and
what people have done a lot in the past
is you would put a two norm on this s
and this is this is what we did when we
looked at the singular value
decomposition for underdetermined
systems is we solved for the minimum two
norm solution of the system of equations
but when you solve for the minimum two
norm system this is what you get okay so
this is the S that has the minimum two
norm that satisfies this system of
equations C times psi is Theta here ok
and notice that s is kind of dense
it has a little bit of energy in all of
its entries and that's what this two
norm does the two norm spreads out the
error in the the entries of s so that
you have the smallest radius possible
but every term is active okay
and so this s most certainly does
satisfy this system of equations but
it's not at all sparse it's not the
solution that we want okay and so
instead of doing the two norm what we
can do is put in this one norm here okay
and the one norm I'm going to tell you
all about the one norm later but what
the one norm does is it promotes
solutions of the system that have as
many zero entries as possible so when
you solve for the minimum one norm
solution this is what you get you
actually find the original solution s
that is as sparse as possible so if
you're looking for solutions s to this
system of equations that are as sparse
as possible this is the kind of
optimization that you want to be solving
you want to minimize the error in the
fit we know C we know PI we know why
we're solving for s such that S has the
minimum one norm and that's going to
give me the sparseness possible solution
and that's going to allow me to solve
solve this problem in a in a convex
optimization so okay I'm gonna point out
a couple of other things this is really
important because this is a convex
optimization problem which means that
it's not combinatorially hard it even
when your problem gets bigger and bigger
and bigger even when this matrix and the
specter get bigger and bigger and bigger
this scales efficiently with Moore's law
so the you know the bigger the problem
you have you can just wait for computers
to get faster and you can solve those
bigger problems whereas before solving
this this optimization problem was
combinatorially hard if you double the
size of your problem it might take a
million years for your computers to get
faster with Moore's law to solve it okay
so I'm glossing over a lot of stuff here
I'll tell you more about kind of what I
mean by convex optimization and
combinatorially hard and Moore's law and
all of those things later we'll talk
about
but what I want to point out is the
problem we actually want to solve is the
minimum zero norm because the zero norm
of s literally counts how many nonzero
entries there are in s but this is not
convex you can't solve this efficiently
with computers and so the big advance in
that that early 2000s I was talking
about is showing that if you replace
that with a one norm with high
probability this will converge to the
sparse solution that we actually want
okay so that's really the big idea here
in compress sensing is that we're gonna
find the sparse a solution to this
underdetermined problem using l1
regularized optimization there's other
ways you can write this I'll just write
down one more for you before I go you
could also write this as minimize the
one norm of s such that this si si s
minus y equals zero the two normal that
equals zero okay you could also minimize
this s1 subject to some constraint on
this being true and in many cases if you
have some measurement noise so Y is not
exactly C times I times s but there's
some measurement noise this might not be
exactly equal to 0 and so you can say
that this has to be the minimum one norm
subject to this error being less than
some epsilon or some threshold okay so
takeaway here is that there are lots of
ways of writing this optimization
problem and the l1 norm will promote the
Sparsit solution out of all of the
infinitely many solutions to this
underdetermined problem the l1 norm is
going to give us the sparsa solution and
remember just to take a step back that s
is my vector of Fourier coefficients
which we know is sparse for natural
signals so once I solve for this sparse
s I can reconstruct my full image just
by inverse Fourier transform ok it
sounds like magic it is absolutely not
there are rigorous conditions on
what kinds of measurements you can take
how many you need and when this
optimization will and will not converge
so that's all coming up and then we'll
code this up in Python and in MATLAB
okay thank you